Palestinian officials have branded in
Washington as draft peace plan with
Israel a bribe adding that is
unacceptable to trade national freedom
for money Donald Trump and his
son-in-law Jared Kushner call it and the
deal of the century
it offers billions in investment in
exchange for political concessions when
we looked at the Palestinians we said
well what are the opportunities that
they can have what's been holding them
back economically I think we built a
very good business plan under the deal
there would be heavy investment into
Palestine which in return would have to
relinquish claim to the occupied
territories in Jerusalem and a state
called new Palestine would be
established within the borders of the
West Bank and the Gaza Strip though it
would be forbidden from having an army
Paula slea reports American president
Donald Trump might think he's dangling a
carrot by offering Palestinian
businessman tens of billions of dollars
if they sign up to his much touted peace
plan which is still shrouded in secrecy
but it reportedly offers Palestinians
sovereignty although not a full state
and it allows Israel to annex the large
settlement blocs but here in Ramallah
the message is a resounding no thank you
I am in front of the headquarters of one
of the largest companies in information
technology in Palestine after receiving
an invitation from President Trump to
attend the conference next month in
Bahrain to discuss things its chairman
says it was quite frankly insulted
actually I was surprised the invitation
is for this conference they called it
that is for developing the Palestinian
economy from my personal perspective I
see it's not a successful conference I
see it it's actually insulation for the
Palestinian community and for the
Palestinian businesspeople because it
came out of scope it came like a sudden
one it was a big surprise for us the
political situation is very bad the US
administration unfortunately and the
latest thing that they did in the last
two years was all of it were always
towers standing beside Israel and
putting between conditions and putting
decisions against us the meeting in
Bahrain is supposed
Palestinian business leaders the
benefits they'll reap and at a so-called
American deal of the century but without
being consulted as to what exactly the
details of that deal entail the official
word from the Palestinian leadership is
we do not trade our national whites for
money business leaders here say they
will not be bought with cash but it's in
economy is suffering heavily everybody
knows that they were seen economy is in
a bad situation actually the World Bank
and IMF are saying that we are almost in
recession of course helping the
Palestinian economy is important but
this is not the way if we want to look
for what the Palestinian economy is
suffering from number one is the
occupation so they were speaking about
issues of billions and at the same time
then ignoring the reasons why the
Brazilian economy is suffering with the
Palestinians who has the problem if they
are not speaking to us and they will
speak alone I don't know how they can
implement that plan if they want to
enforce the plan they can the u.s. is a
strong country they can enforce a plan
but this plan will not succeed it's
taken Trump more than two years to reach
this point his son-in-law Jared Kushner
who was tasked with working out the
details has been meeting with Arab
countries to bring them on board but for
Trump for whom the art of the deal is
everything he's about to learn that at
least here buying his way to a deal
seemingly does not work policy er arty
Ramallah
you